all right well you know I I saw
something the other day I wandered over
to the administrative side of the office
mm-hmm Andy and I we stay in one side of
the office and up will they actually do
the real work of the show up towards the
front with the reception area you got
over the barrier Yeah right like what i
clawed over the little doggie game that
they put up to keep us away and I was
over in that section of Millie and I saw
this bike messenger come up and and and
deliver like a tube of information you
know here to our show of pure liquid
information your liquid information and
he came in and he gave us you know he
delivered this and then he went dashing
off and I thought look at this guy think
bike messengers are the coolest they
really are they're they're like they're
like guys from the Pony Express were in
the old wagon out of traffic
yeah I'm a they they're it's dangerous
job they kind of live alone they look
cool they come dashing in they give the
information they dash out again they're
probably underpaid but doing it anyway
because they're living on the edge and I
just thought this is a very cool thing
being a bike messenger and I got it in
my head and be really cool to try and be
a bike messenger for a day you know I
really did I thought it would be a neat
thing to do why do people giggle at that
I thought being a bike messenger would
be a neat thing and so a couple of days
ago I called a bike messenger service
and offered you know to be one right
here in New York City for an entire day
and deliver messages and we filmed
exactly what happened and here's the
adventure enjoy okay Steve
first of all do you have any experience
at all riding in New York City traffic
on a bicycle absolutely none okay we're
gonna keep you pretty much local we're
gonna keep you within a 20 23rd Street
don't feel like you have to baby nice no
I know baby you need to go I mean you
don't have to keep me in like a small
area if you've got a package that you
need in New Jersey I'll cross the damn
bridge if I have to I'll get there I
brought an outfit okay that I thought
would look pretty cool and maybe I'll
get into that now that's a good idea
what do you think hey and check this out
I brought my own helmet look enough
jibber-jabber I think it's time I go
grunt and get on the bike no you have to
talk to the chief dispatcher now oh okay
well that's hey guys how you doing how
are you so she talked to the dispatcher
that's me all right and I'm gonna go out
and I guess like the rest these guys are
gonna deliver some messages huh all
right you guys got piercings and stuff
what is that I've never seen one of
those that's so cool man
it's called a what a Madison Oh in my
day they call that a tracheotomy
all right well can't I guess you and I
are you're gonna show me the ropes out
there on the street right you're gonna
show me what to do
huh all right thank you very much all
right where am I going Chelsea Piers
click bottles
a modeling agency there you go right
this is great
okay well let's hey guys get out there
and peddle is that is that what they say
so can't talk to me about my bike what
am i doing right what am i doing wrong
well well Tony of course no it's purple
purple really yeah you got the purple
tassel if you look like a cheerleader
for you
the Nexus combination come on yeah I'd
take a mom okay I thought they were kind
of fun but all right you know fun isn't
always cool okay do you like this look
boss like this is a boss bike yeah that
was cool it's not really a boss fight
okay finally just before we go last on
the helmet would go with it or not and
just be honest be brutally honest
what the hell go for it I wish you had
said take it off not let's try one where
you say take it off what about the
helmet and be brutally honest lose it do
it yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
okay should is up to you no don't bother
don't bother yeah nobody's gonna take
that yeah very nice hello how are you
just making the pickup why are you
laughing
you see those girls
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm kind of a loner you know I kind of
play by my own rules
yeah danger
[Music]
we've got to go down to Wall Street pick
up two down there come back up through
the Midtown we got about another three
or four more all right I think I got a
better way to do this oh yeah
[Music]
yes hi yes I'm a messenger with cavalry
couriers we had a problem with your wine
delivery
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
folks we're gonna take a little break
when we come back great for any guy jim
breuer is gonna join us we'll see you